[Music]
in not on my watch buddy news submitted
by through you from twice twice I'll add
the k-pop group ah the corium poppers do
the name right I don't I don't know all
any of the members OD honest I only know
the group name this is funky I tried I'm
so sorry
a woman attempts to fix her
neighborhoods speeding problem in the
most hilarious way she just stood in the
middle of the road naked
slow down stop yeah so this one does
anyone else wanna guess so I've been
naked woman another road if L were up to
me I'd probably get those nail strips
that the police have and I just throw
them in the streets everywhere so you're
so negative
lemon all the police are the ones that
came up with that take nature to get
criminal I would put I even go slow you
could pop your tire this is Anna I would
put posters of really hot people that
would crash oh maybe we'll crash all
over if it wasn't pretty whatever slow
down no they're not going to slow down
they're just going to drive with the and
we should revoke their license for being
stupid I would just put cones so they
don't go down my street oh look at the
Main Street like this ladies it's not a
Main Street but it's like that street is
pretty busy so they connect to another
major why does she need people to slow
down anyway they're a neighborhood she
says there's children that get dropped
off so can't they get like a slow
children playing Saldanha high and then
go to City Hall and say hey City Hall
city hall meeting we need those speed
bumps maybe but we got the hilarious way
oh hello in mind
hello no because like I was wondering
why didn't she do it the official way
cuz she wants to be funny she saw the
community well first of all it does take
place in the UK so I don't know how
their procedures about gum spinning
speed on same goes you know I can't
think of anything I was just thinking of
her just like like standing in the
middle of the road and when a car comes
up then she just lays flat okay that's
what else that's morbid downsell yummy
fever with her own body yeah I'm crazy
enough laughs it's okay Joe just
homework I'll show you guys you ready
yeah it's gonna be a video okay I use a
hairdryer Oh does he protect America
hilarious but can't they tell that she's
not a cop doesn't matter ever since she
started doing this in front of her home
she's seen a dramatic reduction in all
the I think about you I don't think it's
because they think it's a speed they're
like who's this half naked old granny
with a freaking hair dryer and she does
this all day yeah as well I'll go into
that later but first I'll show you guys
this video
that guy did not slow down at all using
the brake lights go on when you've got
cars and vice going down you know to
stop and children now I say thank you
lady pleasuring nice and cuddly but I
know freedom gang of bikers quite simply
by picking up on a zone and going like
that I have never seen so many people's
great lights go on and all it is is a
hairdryer if they don't like it as tough
I live here my friends live here my
friends children live here and ago he's
not safe in our own streets how the hell
are we going to say in the world we have
a neighborhood watch grannies like her
that'll go out there with tan lines and
blow people without them yeah I think
this next is my favorite photo for them
okay she's like gotcha yeah so cute
she's awesome
I actually knew someone that did that
like they he like he brought out like a
hair dryer and then like you start
seeing car slow down you know the most
interesting people I need to buy her
uniform
you need us not being friends with all
those people you're naming yeah you know
dudes wear uniforms I don't really talk
to offers anymore but yeah I wonder if a
banana will work a banana and this
father was really good as he's
representing yeah I subpoena that would
bring the cops in the cops
good Robert haha I know in LA you
probably shot first first before they
even ask any questions but yeah so this
lady her name is Jean she's 64 years old
she's retired clearly yeah so should no
arguing no she's saying that she's lived
in this place for about a year and that
she noticed that a lot of you know cars
and motorcycle groups they would be
zooming patzert on I'd be pissed she's a
new neighbor
I'd like you don't have any right to
tell us what to do try keep yours
[ __ ] Ustream they've been racing
bikes down here for the past 20 years
and you're gonna come out here is just
low dryer know what she moved in for a
year she's trying to change the culture
of the neighborhood yeah she's not
blending with the locals yeah if
everyone's raising you got a raise huh I
can't tell you that her neighbors are
really thankful that she's doing this
because now they feel way bigger [ __ ]
through time and Scully why jeez why did
he do that maybe they wanted to solve
this problem but they couldn't until she
came hard she seems like a [ __ ] hot
woman a [ __ ] gun holders shouldn't go
does she seem pretty testable yeah she
looks like mama walrus she just like a
cool mama like she has his fucked-up tan
line and she's like I'll give a [ __ ] my
kids about to pop out but I got to tell
you about is what the blow dryer [ __ ]
I'm doing how do you even get a 10 in
the UK she got this like while Valley
the day with a hair dryer make sure sure
[ __ ] gloomy as [ __ ] out there you
know what she's saying that um her
son-in-law first under logs death like
after he died which I'm not sure how he
passed away but after an immunity
blow-dried probably okay da [ __ ]
explode today what you sayin actually
she just dedicated all of her time in to
fund raising money for this Cancer
Center and so she created this cafe in
her front yard and so that's where she
just has people just come and sit and
drink good cup of tea and then they can
make donations to this Cancer Foundation
and our campus Cancer Center
she's dull yeah so then she's saying
like you know now that she has all these
people and she's like you know bringing
the community together because she's
saying that she remembers back in the
50s and 60s after they had gone over the
war how everyone was all about community
they were all about you know just being
there for each other so she was trying
to create that that environment in her
new neighborhood and so now that with
this cafe and the fact that she's
slowing down all the the speed speed
drivers she's bringing community
together
you know what will bring community
together is if the neighbor across the
street and her
get trip wire all the motorcycle people
come they go one two three
what move and in the blocks across the
street high five
that brings people together I don't
think she's trying to hurt people I am
so that be her illusion I would I think
I would bond with my neighbors so well
if we were able to do that and if they
fall it's like hey there's a children or
another good way is instead of having
the blow-dryer go a little bit go a
little bit bigger and get a leaf blower
and they get a pile of [ __ ] leaves and
as soon as the motorcycle drives like a
bus and the [ __ ] leads to a trailer
and nothing crash because you can't see
we're gonna really hit kids then right
and then the cops come you were just
gardening yeah I like that I like that
how about you get a big-ass fan and blow
back I can't go forward and they're
trade-offs that we pretty cool no wonder
she doesn't motorcycle games I Drive by
her neighborhood they're always trying
to like pop off like wheelies and doot
doot try to cop off they're trying to
like do some trick to impress the school
girls I get dropped off in that same
area that 16 year old girl hi her for me
and resolved I swear they might be high
school kids too that just left school
yeah like judgment yeah
bicycle gang guys it's pretty funny too
huh she came to have all this attention
because there was this she called in to
BBC radio after they had asked if there
was if anyone had a solution for people
like riding around in their bikes and
speeding past their neighborhoods nuts
when she called an and after like people
heard her tell her her solution everyone
just loved her and then that's when the
BBC went out they made this video that I
showed you guys and then this thing went
viral within 24 hours I had more than 12
minutes million views oh yeah
but then no motorcycle gangs know it so
they just go oh that's all that was
there is gonna go back down
wow they just ruined a whole plan they
just keep that tripwire lady take it to
the next level
or big fan or that are machine-gun yeah
I think I like the machine gun that'll
really build community because she did
say after the war right so like what
brings people together war ha ha ha
you wanted a group [ __ ] answer no well
I mean like that so in the 50s and 60s
everyone came together after the war so
they need to make a little war locally
or something a little bit safer like you
know those t-shirt cannons yeah so
you're giving them a free shirt but
they're losing a leg and then the shirt
the shirt will market her cafe Oh
charity yep it'll bring the community
together no what I was going to mention
earlier though that that was really cute
is that
when the video started going viral that
her daughter called her up and she was
like mom you're going viral she was like
viral I'm not sick at all what are you
talking about and then that's what she's
like that's cute excuse me only she took
that picture though yeah that's a thing
like her more and more
ASSA the more news I find out about her
I want her on my side
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out of here
[Music]